Nicola Anna
welcome to to Scandinavia thank you so
much for coming thank you very much um
yeah so from formative instant the the
show has been a bit depressing so far so
you count on me to bring some sake
that's what that's what we thought well
it is a depressing topic we're going to
talk about because we we got to talk
about the is you know them better than
most people you've been their prisoner
for ten months and I wonder as as a
Frenchman living in Paris what were your
first thoughts when when they attack
Paris when that evening I I heard all
the sirens of the police cars and
ambulances rushing at the scene of the
attacks and and then I i could hear some
of the some of the shooting and this
sound it's crazy because to me it's
familiar because i'm a war reporter says
I'm used to the sound of machine guns
but still not home so I was shocked even
though I know that these people are
looking to do these kind of attacks so I
wasn't surprised and I'm Fred that these
kind of attacks could happen again in
Paris or anywhere in Europe tell me we
we we've seen the ious soldiers like we
saw them here on the clip with with with
black masks black black flags like like
this evil force but try to enlighten us
who are they they were your guards I
mean yes exactly so I I know them
intimately somehow and the fact is that
there is there still a big difference
between the image that report as a way
supporter themself and this propaganda
clips were on which you have some kind
of I would almost say advertised ation
of violence because violence is so
extreme that the they made it just like
just like a porn movie it's it's
obsessive for them
and but when you you see them on their
daily life daily routine it's extremely
trivial done just normal guys how I mean
are they normal in the sense that that
they are similar to us I mean somehow I
mean I had to deal with with a lot of
jihad is coming from European countries
and most of my jurors were actually
coming from European countries where
must be speaking either French or
English with us and so they can be an
European languages yes of course and and
and the some of them would barely speak
Arabic they this is what are the main
strands of eyes it's that they they
succeeded in some kind of synthesis
between the local people and people
coming from our countries and I actually
a couple of your guards were you were
you were captured in raka right yes and
which is a one of the capital cities of
the FI yes yes and you moved around a
bit yes you're in captivity but but one
of your guards was was made in a moosh
yes a suspected killer of the Jewish
Museum in Brussels in Brussels right uh
yeah tell me how was he I mean what can
you tell he's extremely childish and
very narcissistic it would say it was he
spent hours with us telling us about
French TV shows and he wanted to be the
star of one of these shows which which
is about criminal affairs and I had the
feeling that he has done all this he has
been to Syria only to have one of these
shows and about him just on him they
wanted to be star of a TV show and
that's why by the way I I've chosen
jihad Academy as a title of the book
ever written after hands because to some
extent
is is a kind of crazy production company
making a reality TV so to bring fame to
people who have no life you there was
another guy as well presumed dead now
recently he had a Jon we had your murder
of seven of my former cellmates who were
hostages with me and who were killed and
is a suspected while the confirmed
murder of five of them and and what can
I did you had to know whether this guy
was extremely violent it was he wanted
to look like the mastermind of all this
enterprise of hostage taking and and it
was it was mad but somehow smart most of
these girls are are mostly stupid or
childish but it was a it was smart well
in knew very well how to manipulate
especially the Western public opinions
and I think that he was behind most of
the most horrific videos that we have
seen online and how did I mean when
there were these this physical though
this is a psychological terror that they
also how did you deal Nate that's a lot
this this is part of their childish
state of mind I would say I mean we were
lies our toys for them their website for
an exchange but up to until this
exchange we're like you're well we were
lies our pets so they would come and
play with us if not physically at least
at least mentally one day one guy with
the pop up in the cell and tell us well
tomorrow we will release you and then
when we can letter
the very same guy would come and tell us
tomorrow we'll kill one of you that's it
just for fun did you I mean how did you
respond to that did you the only
response is you have fortunately in this
kind of circumstances a kind of well the
survival instinct comes and it is based
on flatline so basically whatever
happens you just try to stay flat line
and this is the only way to survive what
one of you were actually we're actually
executed while you you were your
incapacity